dunque iniziamo guardare questa immagine
voi sapete che l'elettronica usa
elementi come l'arsenico silicio metalli
pesanti plastiche sono cose molto
diverse dai dagli elementi dagli
alimenti naturali quelli per esempio che
ci troviamo su una tavola
e pensare che questi due mondi possono
andare insieme difficile c'è un enorme
divario no io se vi faccio vedere questo
penso voi vi immaginate che non funziona
infatti non funziona la sfida però che
cv porto oggi è di cercare di mettere
insieme questi mondi alla per farlo una
di cominciare a chiedersi come mai come
sono fatte le molecole biologiche e
quindi farsi domande fondamentali da
dove viene la vita e qual è la chimica
fondamentale la natura avendo a
disposizione più di 100 elementi fa
quasi tutto con solo questi sei
sostanzialmente cioè il 99 per cento
della nostra massa di un uomo è fatto da
quei sei elementi
questo può sembrare strano quindi vuol
dire che io e george clooney siamo fatti
degli stessi atom è tutta una questione
di come vengono messi assieme
potevamo stare più attenti però vabbè è
così
ora tra questi elementi non è non è una
questione di abbondanza ce n'è uno che è
privilegia più importante che ha
privilegiato chi è il carbonio non per
l'abbondanza perché il secondo per
esempio nel nostro corpo ma perché lui è
eclettico dal punto di vista chimico è
un atomo che cambia i legami chimici a
seconda della situazione lui a 4
elettroni più esterne che usa per i
legami che sono come quattro braccia ea
volte si legga altri quattro vicini a
volte 3 e c'è un elettrone libero a
volte due ci sono due elettroni liberi
questo cambia radicalmente le proprietà
degli elementi
vi faccio un esempio per esempi il
diamante è fatto di carbonio e
coordinato con altri quattro atomi e non
ci sono elettroni liberi e noi
conosciamo il diamante come una sostanza
trasparente durissima e un isolante dal
punto di vista elettrico la grafite
invece è sempre fatta dal carbonio ma lì
c'è un elettrone libero premiato che si
muove nella struttura e quindi la
grafite è opaca nera assorbe tutta la
luce è un conduttore elettrico ed è
molto friabile fatto li vedete il
grafene in realtà perché è un foglio di
grafite poi il carbonia fa ancora altri
altre strutture diverse e lo troviamo
nel più importanti molecole biologiche
per esempio nel dna le basi hanno una
struttura chimica per questo che si dice
che era la vita si basa sul carbonio per
la struttura chimica e anche alcune
reazioni chimiche fondamentali
coinvolgono il carbonio ancora le
proteine sono catene di aminoacidi e i
singoli aminoacidi vedete in verde
vedete il dovere dove il carbonio o
ancora i colori in natura quelli che
sono dovuti ai pigmenti naturali
derivano da composti del carbonio in
questo caso da catene di atomi di
carbonio
bene allora siccome ci sono alcuni
composti che possono trasportare la
carica elettrica
noi sappiamo se non c'erano è stata
sviluppata una tecnologia che sa fare
dei dispositivi utilizzando dei polimeri
a base di carbonio che sono sintetizzati
e poi vengono messi insieme ai materiali
più standard
l'idea che voglio condividere con voi
oggi è quella di guardare agli elementi
che vi mostro qua non come la dispensa
di un poco ma come la cassetta degli
attrezzi di un ingegnere a pezzi sono
ingredienti naturali alimenti naturali
bene noi siamo in grado di costruire un
transistor che abbiamo sentito
stamattina trans east e l'unità
dell'elettronica digitale un
interruttore che fa 0 e 1 utilizzando
quegli elementi quegli alimenti abbiamo
fatto vedere elementi che siano che sono
naturali sostanze naturali più vedete un
esempio c'è un substrato con la seta c'è
l'albumina c'è la gomma lacca così uno
intanto che fa un transistor può
mangiare qualcosa farsi le unghie c'è
una serie di funzionalità e otteniamo
dei dispositivi che sono non solo bio
compatibili dispositivi vuol dire che
funziona e che hanno una funzione
trasportano del sul comporta come
transistor sono bio compatibili sono
addirittura commestibili e qui torniamo
a dall'aglio sono lì può condire poi e
cosa ci facciamo risolto la domanda se
va bene bravo e quindi cosa facciamo per
esempio noi possiamo mettere
informazione nei cibi e quindi avere un
tracking un'informazione dalla
produzione fino all'utilizzatore finale
o anche dallo scaffale del supermercato
avere una comunicazione informazione
sulla provenienza di origini che cosa è
successo il trattamento perché siamo in
grado di mettere non delle banali
etichette ma dei sistemi che sono in
grado di fare delle misure a mandare dei
segnali non è solo nella confezione ma
possiamo andare nel nell'alimento ma
possiamo fare anche di più possiamo
realizzare il sogno del viaggio
allucinante di asimov cioè possiamo
portare il medico dentro al corpo umano
facendo delle capsule che non sono
semplicemente dei farmaci chimici ma
sono dei dispositivi che dal dentro al
corpo svolgono delle funzioni per
esempio fanno delle misure locali
mi sono ossigeno temperatura ph oppure
fanno delle misure elettriche oppure
verificano la presenza di un'infezione
batterica che è utilissimo sarebbe per
gli ospedali e poi comunicano col medico
che dal suo cellulare riceve il
messaggio e vede che in quel paziente
sta succedendo qualcosa e poi
intervenire e non dobbiamo preoccuparci
che queste capsule devono attraversare
se si fermano all'interno è pericoloso
perché vengono totalmente digerite non è
neanche assorbite proprio digerite
perché sono elementi commestibili e
possiamo anche pensare di affrontare
sfide ancora aperte
qui vedete come vedi un paziente che ha
la retinite pigmentosa a una certa fase
della malattia
ci sono alcune cecità che sono causate
dalla degenerazione dei fotorecettori
della retina e una è la rete più ventosa
l'altra è la degenerazione maculare
entrambe queste malattie sono
progressive non sostanzialmente non c'è
una cura e portano alla cecità completa
e quello che ne abbiamo realizzato è una
protesi fatta con questi nostri
materiali essendo biocompatibili che si
sostituisce ai fotorecettori qui vedete
l'occhio vedete una proiezione del fondo
della rete dove ci sono i fotorecettori
che ricevono la luce la trasforma in un
segnale bioelettrico che poi attraverso
il nervo ottico va al cervello come
sempre succede con sistemi praticamente
sofisticate importanti come l'occhio per
noi le cose a volte posso andar male
possono smettere di funzionare se i
fotorecettori scompaia malattia vengono
totalmente degradati non si vedono più
noi possiamo sostituirli con la nostra
protesi che viene sistemata in posizione
sub retinica e la vedete lì al posto dei
fotorecettori questo grazie a grazie a
pertile che è un chirurgo oculista che
si presta aiutarci in questi esperimenti
di solito opera su human è un'esperta di
retina invece opera su animali da
laboratorio per aiutarci a sperimentare
questa nostra idea
la protesi che noi usiamo non è fatto di
silice come immaginavate è fatta
ovviamente di questi composti di
carbonio e quindi è molto più
biocompatibile qui vedete che la
molecola che noi usiamo che quella che
voi vedete a sinistra e quasi molto
simile diciamo aretina le che è il
cromoforo naturale che abbiamo nella
retina fra l'altro è curioso il fatto
che i cromofori che ne abbiamo negli
occhi sono molto simili ai pigmenti che
ci sono in natura che danno i colori e
poi mente non è un caso nell'evoluzione
biologica questi pigmenti sono entrati
nei tessuti e nelle cellule e poi via
via negli organismi hanno sviluppato un
organo sempre più complesso che è
diventato l'occhio quindi peraltro
mangiare carote poi sarebbe essere vero
che fa bene alla vista perché e sono
legate alle molecole che che noi abbiamo
qui vedete che la nostra protesi è
perfettamente conforme al fondo
dell'occhio perché ha la giusta
flessibilità e questa una cosa molto
difficile ottenere la retina è uno
spazio estremamente delicato e curvo e
la incidente con un capello
semplicemente quindi bisogna avere
qualcosa che non è troppo rigido
i primi tentativi usavamo substrato di
plastica comune
quando guarda vi sembra aver messo un
mattone nell'occhio di vedere una cosa
fuori da questa invece è molto smooth
questa è una misura fatta da maurizio
mente che un altro chirurgo oculista che
un esperto di questa tecnica che si
chiama tomografia coerente ottica che
viene usata per vedere per esempio al
fondo dell'occhio la retina
ora bisogna capire funzionano e non è
facile con degli animali da laboratorio
che non parlano ovviamente ma una cosa
che possiamo fare è una serie di studi e
con i neuro scienziati per vedere se c'è
il recupero della funzione qui vi faccio
vedere un esempio che abbiamo fatto vari
esperimenti vedete un occhio ceco
operato e vedete che la pupilla chiede
se riuscissi a vedere perché non hanno
un iride colorata provvedete qualche in
quanto noi arriviamo con la luce si
restringe questo è un esempio per dirvi
come si fa a capire se l'occhio funziona
ovviamente facciamo altri esperimenti e
abbiamo delle prove concrete che gli
animali cechi sono modificati
geneticamente sviluppano la malattia
recuperano la vista ora per adesso si
tratta di animali da laboratorio
si tratta di un'operazione che può
recuperare la vista in chi ha una
degenerazione dei fotorecettori ma tutto
il resto compreso il nervo ottico che
dal cervello perfettamente funzionante
quindi c'è ancora moltissima strada da
fare non voglio dare illusioni ma penso
di poter portare una speranza e vi
lascio con un aneddoto che riguarda il
carbonio e che a me ricorda che io uso
sempre ricordarmi che i composti del
carbonio sono conduttori elettrici non
sono solo le plastiche delle delle
bottiglie per esempio o il diamante nel
1928 la spedizione di nobile rientrava
dal polo e come sapete ha incontrate mpo
terribile una tempesta e forse a causa
la manovra sbagliata somma dirigibile
perde quota sbatte contro la banchina la
nave si rompe in due pezzi ci sono delle
perdite e alcuni superstiti sono
sbalzati sulla banchina dove costruisca
una famosa tenda rossa e tra questi c'è
la c'è il marconista e lacko la sua
radio però la radio non funziona non
funziona perché manca una resistenza e
qui c'è
il colpo di genio del del marconi sta
ovviamente immaginate siamo al polo con
una tempesta in corso sulla banchina
anche uno può andare a trovare una
resistenza elettrica facilmente ma lui
ha una matita una matita in tasca quella
che usava per prendere appunti poi mente
per disegnare non so e gli viene in
mente di usare la grafite dalla matita
per riparare la radio perché la grafite
è un conduttore e lui in questo modo con
la grafite della matita è riuscita a
fare la resistenza giusta per mandare il
primo segnale di soccorso
questa è una storia di un aneddoto che
quindi per per chiudere posso dire ci
disse che la vita viene dal carbonio e
in questo caso il carbonio ha salvato
una vita a me dice anche un esempio del
fatto che essere creativi innovare vuol
dire guardare ciò che c'è intorno tutti
i giorni e vedere qualcosa di diverso e
quindi chiude proprio con schopenhauer
che sicuramente più interesse più
sveglio di me quindi ruba una frase e
lui ha detto il genio non è quello che
colpisce un bersaglio cui gli altri non
riescono arrivare ma è quello che
colpisce un bersaglio che gli altri non
vedono
grazie